so I had a psychotherapist called Adam
Lane Smith on my podcast and he has
dealt with attachment issues and
depression from both men and women for
decades and he said that male depression
gets treated like female depression men
are made to feel loved and accepted when
all they want to do is feel capable and
Powerful give a man a purpose and the
ability to achieve it and he will crawl
over broken glass with a smile and I
think that feeling capable and powerful
and competent and respected and admired
something that will get a man so far you
give a man those things he'll deal with
suffering until he ends of the Earth
We're designed to do that we're designed
to suffer we're designed to deal with
that suffering but it needs to be in
service of something